far from home wouldn't be the same movie
without its incredible special effects
everything from touching up spidey's
suits to creating the elementals
required multiple companies
hundreds of people and hours of work so
we'll spend this video breaking down
their additions to the film
and just how incomplete it would look
without them in every interview
when i wear the bubble hat and i'm like
no you didn't
far from home's most memorable scene has
got to be the intense illusion battle
the big midway fight sequence of the
film frame store
the company in charge of the sequence
was given an unusual amount of freedom
to create the scene
they weren't given a set script to
follow instead
they were given the creative freedom to
come up with the concepts for the
illusions at the same time they were
animating
and adding effects to the shots this
gave them the unique opportunity to
provide direction for the onset
production team
for example with this shot where mj is
attacked by mysterio
frame store blocked out the animation
ahead of time with a cgmj
complete with precise lighting from the
moon and lights of the eiffel tower
this rendered footage was passed along
to the set production
who were able to recreate the exact
lighting frame store needed for the shot
this allowed them to slip zendaya's
performance into the final product
looking absolutely perfect by the way
the construction site where the battle
takes place
100 cg frame store created the entire
building model
adding tom holland's mocap footage on
top they used a mocap suit
instead of filming tom in costume to
save time on set
all of those reality bending illusions
would have meant way too many costume
changes for just
one sequence that nightmare inducing
zombie iron man
utilized mocap as well frame store went
through
several designs for the undead hero
finding the right balance to be
horrifying
without showing anything too gruesome
the final product finds a good middle
ground
resembling a mummy beneath the broken
bits of machinery
marvel moviegoers are no stranger to the
incredible holograms of this cinematic
universe
which means the vfx teams have to keep
their designs consistent with the marvel
style
while putting in a few new twists to
keep the visuals from getting stale
for long time fans for this scene where
mysterio is introduced as quentin beck
and explains the elemental attacks
filming was done using a special
lightbox table
rising sun pictures had to not only
design and place the holograms in the
scene
but adjust the lighting and colors
depending on which holograms were
showing
to make them look like they were really
in the room with the actors
the work had to be done in layers
sometimes completely removing the
lighting from on set
the lighting in the raw footage lacks
the subtle colors reflecting from the
holograms that don't just make the scene
look pretty but create an atmosphere to
complement the actors performances
sometimes an actor's job boils down to
fighting invisible monsters on set
the scene with the water elemental
battle was filmed on set with
recreations of buildings from venice on
top of a huge pool of water
and blue screens as backdrops while the
scene utilized a ton of cg
most of the stunts were accomplished by
tom and his stunt doubles
luke scott and greg townley i never have
a strong level it's always me
vfx not only hid the wires required to
help tom jump from pole to pole
and volt onto the rialto bridge but
filled in the backgrounds of venice
and of course brought the water
elemental to life
there were no rigs or dummies used for
the monster which
means the actors had to rely on their
imaginations to really sell their
performances
all of that water they were drenched
with was real though
and very cold
similar techniques were used for filming
the scenes in london
while portions of the scenes set on
tower bridge were filmed on location
they also filmed using set pieces such
as the tour bus in front of green
screens
the shots littered with rubble and
broken down cars were set pieces
in front of green screens too for wide
shots imageworks built a complete 3d
model of tower bridge
this model was also used for filming all
the destruction that took place during
the climactic final battle
during all this action we see tons of
drones in various states of despair
imageworks was able to create all of
these broken bots by altering their
original models
the drones were constructed out of
various individual pieces
all coming together to form a single
machine like the water elemental the
drones didn't use
any objects on set as stand-ins to help
the actors visualize the scene
here's what peter's final confrontation
with beck really looked like on set
believe it or not this scene set in a
vibrant field of tulips
was filmed in an empty grassland in the
uk the jet
and all the flowers were cg image engine
had to simulate an entire field of
tulips with natural wind as well as the
jet landing
over two million tulips were simulated
in this scene
there were eight colors and eight
different tulips created for each color
in order to render all of them
efficiently they used a method called
precaching
where software will download data ahead
of time in anticipation of its use
that way the computers weren't forced to
simulate two million flowers at the same
time
stripped of cgi this scene is just tom
holland and john favreau standing in
some grass
did you know imageworks did vfx for all
the previous spider-man movies
that's right they provided effects for
the original trilogy and the amazing
spider-man
producers were actually reluctant to go
to them again for the mcu installments
since they wanted to give the third
iteration of the hero a fresh new look
that was until they saw this test
footage imageworks whipped up to prove
that they were up to the task
that's not tom holland in costume that's
completely cg
the 3d model looked and moved so
convincingly that
even tom holland himself was fooled to
innovate on their previous work they
focused on making mcu's spider-man the
most realistic one
yet they did this by studying
imperfections in tom's movements from
unused takes
and incorporating them into the animated
spider-man moments of hesitation
or getting caught off balance helped
make the cg spidey feel
far more grounded in reality than any of
the previous films
while some of spidey's suits are
completely computer generated
and require a mocap suit even the
costumes on set require digital tweaking
here and there
it can be as simple as removing wrinkles
to keep the suit looking smooth
or adding wear and tear from the intense
action sequences
following in tony stark's footsteps
peter enters the workshop in the back of
the jet to build his own suit for the
first time since he ran around queens in
sweats
while the shots of peter entering are
all cg there was also a physical set for
the workshop
after filming tom on set the holograms
were added in post with vfx
image engine had to create an exact
replica of the set
in order to accurately layer the
holograms and moving machinery over the
real footage
bringing the workshop to life in the
final product this scene isn't just an
important character moment for peter
but a chance for the audience to see
what goes into building a stark tech
spidey suit
image engine had to decide what the
individual elements of the suit would
look like
ultimately breaking it down into three
layers for the construction process
there is a white wet fiber layer a layer
of black and red fabric detailing
and a layer for hard surfaces such as
the eyepieces and chest patches
the company in charge of vfx for the
final battle in london
imageworks kept these details consistent
when adding battle damage to the suit
if we look at his suit closely during
his emotional reunion with mj
we can see patches of white material
where the suit sustained damage
before we go here's a bonus fact marvel
is
so serious about keeping spoilers from
leaking that even the vfx teams have to
follow strict rules
working without internet access and
never sending images or emails